I'm not super heavy on consumption the  degree of my consumption is mostly as  silly as the sounds are stuff just to  make sure that it's like looking okay  proofing our own stuff is like I would  say 70 which sounds ridiculous but it is  that's also because it's a very small  percentage to be fair it's a small  percentage of my time and then the other  30 is if you looked at my Twitter the  vast majority of people that I follow  are philosophy stuff so it's like you  know what I mean if you look at my  Instagram the only people that I'm  really following are people that I want  to just see what they're doing rather  than consuming their content I just want  to see like understand their strategy  either Cadence how they caption stuff  are they doing anything new because I'm  new into that world I'm just trying to  learn I don't have any specific people  that I consume a lot from I mean most of  my learning comes from doing